[Music]
[Applause]
hey GQ I'm back
this is defy him Alexander and today I'm
working with chest 8k a shampoo papi to
show you how to get that down to global
come on chance gonna miss chairman
father barber about to be blessed by the
best we're appreciate you man man as you
can see like my hair is like wild and
crazy and curly and I really respect
childish gambino having that freedom and
his hair and wear blue he pulls me in
for the haircut is the part I've never
had a part my department let's do it
this is like these where the clean-cut
look this is a community and naturally
look natural shape up it doesn't have
his beard this one it's like almost the
beginning of his career here right here
is a little longer this is when his
beard first started to up here
initiation of the beard game this is a
beard with a very strong mustache and
for the Luffy they called it this cops -
oh man this one looks like he's rockin
that Club we're blade went to that's the
club I'm trying to go to yes I get my
cut
this is 2018 this is getting closer -
currently when he rocks all had a hair
full beard everything's all grown in so
this is the exact look that I'm trying
to give I can see that you know he's
wearing his beard it's not no 5 o'clock
shadow is pretty much getting thicker
dark yeah it's abduch like a dark she
put his beard soft shading where it's
not like you say like the five o'clock
shadow it's more of a a heavier look
without the actual beard coming out
which is too rough look this is my
favorite photo yeah I like that the back
yeah shadow yeah yeah how does he get
his hair to twist like that like how
does he coil it he paper like something
into his touches here so he can hold it
and lock it while he's reading for a
part or something like that you know
he's - its intense twisting his training
is here so this is gonna be our final
look you see the part you see the smile
is amazing
my man shampoo Bobby you know he wants
to wear this stop it's my job to give it
to him
let's go my very first step would be
shampoo and conditioner Scout I already
did that already perform that this cut
you wanted to be free and loose of any
you know lint in the hair the dirt or
anything like that oil in the scalp
because I'm recreating a style it's
about creating on a clean canvas with
Neela barber well there's like a thing
in the barber shop we're like the hand
is not supposed to kind of it's true
the hand is never supposed to be here
there's two things in the barber shop
you know dude you don't keep your
handing you you don't make eye contact
specifically when you're doing the
mustache you don't want to be like
that's like real awkward yeah like a
little pixie you know on you on your
right your left arm
looks like what are you looking at yeah
I just I just I don't look at me
whatever you do you make me nervous
so step one get your hands back inside
step two don't make eye contact
keep it aside shampoo step till we want
to blow-dry the hair right here we had
that and his bull dr.colin looks like
something from Star Wars
solve is easy to manage declines here I
want to work with apart first I'll go to
the andis portlets outliner and my
Coleman one apart two hair I know
growing up used to see the women getting
their hair parted I never thought that I
would have to part here in the barber
shop but these are the things that you
have them if I wanted to part at home
we're kind of home what I use you're
gonna use like a smaller comb that has
like no levels because the smaller teeth
would get stuck
so as I'm farting on disco me and so I
can have that line makes it look natural
[Music]
Nathan's product just to keep in style
[Music]
[Music]
so when I go to wash my hair do i
reapply right after the shower yes you
can wear it to the show okay you can
reapply the next day before I do the
shape up on the particular cut I'm gonna
use my cordless masters yes to tape her
around the edges so I have seen when she
see with me taping the edges then lays
it down naturally creating the shape up
and outlining so you can get seek cover
and you know create the side profile I
want to go with the hard edges right
here because I wanted to stand out so
you see the difference right here
tapered shaped up here this is untouched
this picker the master cut sensitive
taking it down or fading it down so you
could put a nice slide in it never want
to go to above its original line you see
here it's like a clean line we finished
the back the back is cool so we want to
create the profile it's kind of going up
up in here and fading everything is
forming on the profile calming down to
life is naturally live starts off though
[Music]
start sketching it and sharp like a
number-two pencil you can make the seat
but Sony point was always popular in the
90s
Will Smith first person biller had that
cut c-cup styles are like 360 they come
back now we can go to his front profile
you don't want to have a crooked here
you want to pull that natural hair down
you don't want to cut up into you want
to take what he has and trim it down
it's a flat surface balance is very
important to me that's the first thing
that people see and they look at your
face going to the cemetery top the
hairline to the point of a bra which is
very important then you could start like
your C cup here so this side is complete
as far as the shaper so I'm gonna move
on to the right side so this cut is
coming along Nino effects okay like you
know he's not a period he just childish
game he had legends legends and icons
can never be a case he is musically
childish gambino and then his acting
professionally definitely Donald Webber
he's sort of like Humpty hump me and my
guys on my block just to argue about I'm
like you know that's shocked Jeep hoppy
hop they the same person so childish
gambino versus the same person person so
you get two checks do you see what I'm
saying
bingo the man is a legend thing go check
out the front you got the amazing part
and we got the side profile so the
neighbor area which is pretty smooth and
clean so that'll be what I'm moving to
is beard and we're just gonna just comb
the beard out so it makes it easier for
the Clipper
to cut
[Music]
positive you
so what a human like a love of the shoes
are because if you go too low there's no
way in the world you can pick the hair
up off the floor put it back on so long
slow motion is very very important so
you'll need an extra spot centimeter
side profile and face just taper it on
just to give it to me
it's not bald and is not too dark so in
case he wants to grow his beer back he
has a starting point o match and meet in
the same location now we have your left
profile same operation there with the
brain everything is cut smooth and even
into the point we are almost done with
the beard we're going back to the ends
outliner so my first order cleaning the
neck area you know getting all the
excess hair off when I have to do my
beards I'd normally just start back here
not born up too high just on the
neckline nothing super super super super
sharp cleaning the scrubs up just be
nasty dirty dirty so one thing guys
always saying I taste my food and I
taste my mustache at the same time could
you make an adjustment something short
here
so the beard is done all this let this
finish the touches got the afro twist
pick people seem to like here people
want to know where to get it from
holding spray
just a blow dryer to make a stick so
this way is my curly racking with the
pick it's just circular motions to get
that those twists those natural twist
then the part I like about this style
here is that you can continue to style
it the pick I don't want you to see the
bald spot did I do it I'm not I gotta be
a work of art I know you nailed it
I'm ready man depression actually really
like this no I'm really bout to kill
some selfies when I go home look at this
boy this is like I'm breaking apart back
I'm not this like a trend I'm the man
with the master plan
they do not please me I really
appreciate you thinking for shampoo
can't be no this is America and for him
is speaking to it thank you guys we just
wrapped up another fantastic episode of
make me look like please leave comments
tell me what you guys want to see
because I can do the coats until next
time thank you